يعطونك الامل ثم يقتلونه فيك هذا بالضبط
ما فعله الكروات مع منتخب البرازيل اليوم
90 دقيقه البرازيل لم تصل الى مرمى
كرواتيا رغم كل المحاولات رغم اللاعبين
المميزين الموجودين هجوميا والمهارات
والسحر البرازيلي لم ينجح في فك شفره
الدفاع الكرواتي 90 دقيقه قادت فيها
كرواتيا ومشهد مباراه
البرازيل الى اشواط اضافيه ولكن هون حدثت
المفاجاه البرازيل سجلت عن طريق نيمار
والجميع ضمن المباراه خلصت وانتهت ولكن مع
كره القدم ما في شيء بينتهي الى سافرت
النهايه لانه كوفيتش عاد وسجل هدف التعادل
الى كرواتيا ورجع المباراه وخلى الخطه تبع
كرواتيا تمشي وتروح على المباراه الترجيح
بالمناسبه كرواتيا من اول ما دخلت
المباراه هي عم تلعب بهذا الخطاب انه تودي
المباراه
تبع كرواتيا في كاس العالم دائما
اصعب مباراه للفرق الكبرى او للفرق اللي
عنده لاعبين مهاريين هي انه تلعب امام
دفاع عميق ومنظم وقوي بدنيا وعنده لياقه
عاليه وفي وراءه حارس كبير تخيل معي انه
البرازيل عملت 11 تسديده اوتار جيت على
المرمى شجره هدف وحيد كرواتيا تسديده
واحده على المرمى بهدف وحيد واخذت مباراه
ركلات ترجيح وبركلات ترجيح كانوفيتش قارئ
جيد للمنتخب البرازيلي راجع قول ما يدخل
على قناه الترجيح وين راحوا لاعبين
البرازيليين وكان جاهز ومتوقع معظم الكرات
بشكل الصحيح وصدر ركله الجزاء وانتهى
الامر وغادره البرازيل بالمقابل الكرواتيا
من الدرب جيدا على ركلات الترجيح وما ضيعت
ولا واحده طبعا ولا راحت الى الدور نصف
النهائي الى انه طبعا هذه نقطه قوه الشاهد
والدرس المستفاد من هذه المباراه انه ما
تحكم على فريق من دور المجموعات او دور
ال16 لما يلعب امام فريق ضعيف بكل امانه
البرازيل ربما اصاب الغرور شويه بنفسها
اكثر ربما اخذتها العاطفي زياده بعد الفوز
على كوريا الجنوبيه برباعيه فكروا انهم
مباراه كرواتيا راح تكون سهله ولكن لو عدت
البرازيل الى نصف النهائي صدقني مباراه
كرواتيا كانت راح تكون الاصعب في هذه
البطوله لانه من الصعب جدا انك تلعب مع
هاي النوعيه من الفرق مع البرازيل بمباراه
سويسرا وفازت واحد صفر بهدف كاسر اكثر
اكثر اكثر اكثر غياب كان مؤثر اليوم
للمنتخب البرازيلي كان غياب اليكس ساندرو
لانه دانيل يلعب مثل ما صار المباراه
الماضيه ولكن هالمره كنت بحاجه لاعب يلعب
لك العرضيات بشكل الصحيح كرواتيا اغلقت
الجهه اليسرى اللي هي مصدر خطوره البرازيل
بشكل كامل خلك فينيسيوس جونيور مش موجود
بالمباراه بسبب لاعبين مهمين جدا طبعا
اسمه غلط ايران وفيتش او هيك شيء
اللي هو الجناح الايمن هذول الاثنين سكروا
الجهه اليسرى بشكل كامل على البرازيل هذه
اول مباراه للمنتخب البرازيلي بتكون فيها
عدد الاختراقات من عمق الملعب اكبر من عدد
الاختراقات من الجهه اليسرى لانه كان
معتمد على نيمار بس اللي هو يحط له جول
وكان هذا مصدر الخطوره ولكن كان في حارس
اسمه لفاكو بيتش جاهز بالمرمى وقادر يصد
كل الكرات وقادر يتعامل مع الهجمات
البرازيليه بالنهايه هذه ربما تكون اكبر
مفاجات كاس العالم 2022 البرازيل كانت
عديمه الحلول لسبب وحيد وخلينا نذكر وهو
بكل صراحه البرازيل تمتلك مهاجمين ولا
تمتلك منظومه هجوميه لا تمتلك سيستم هجومي
افكار هجوميه عند مهاجمين
نعمله شيء ولكن المدرب بيقولوا على الملعب
وعملوا اللي بدكم اياه واتبعوا مهارات
منتهى الامر وهذا شيء لا ينفع مع منتخبات
منظمه مثل المنتخب الكرواتي مبروك لمحبه
المنتخب الكرواتي وهارد لك عشاق المنتخب
البرازيلي هال هذا الخروج المفاجاه
والموجع ولا مغير المتوقع بصراحه ولكن هذه
كره القدم ويجب ان نتعلم منها دائما دروسه
جديده